okay excellent now we just need to move
on to the normal force ok so again I'm
going to drop myself a new diagram good
morning long time they say the scale
repeating it doesn't matter it's which
direction is a faci ok so you can see
the normal is going off that way so this
is the normal ok and then you've got the
two parts of it that matter and then the
rest of the diagram we're just going to
fill in for the sake of completeness
whoops I just drawn all over where
anyway
okay I just like before I mentioned it's
really important it's like it's the
thing right where all of the lights were
all of the actual forces spacing so you
can see I always mark in where is the
point on which all the forces are acting
because everything is going to be
relative to that okay and this is really
nice because like oh this is exactly
what a projectile motion like literally
exactly what a projectile motion diagram
looks like because off it goes was
projected from the origin off in that
direction so I've got this which is and
where is the angle that I'm interested
in where is the end yes so you be
careful so what I want to do is I'm
actually going to add a little bit extra
all to this is one of the advantages of
having extra diagrams the relevant angle
here is alpha here it is alpha is the in
what defines how steep this current is
so therefore it's what defines the
direction of the normal so alpha is over
here free and also measured from the
vertical right so there's the cone is
the actual code okay so you can see if
that's alpha that makes this over here
also alpha because that's vertical okay
but this the whole point of it being the
normal force is that this angle is our
right angle okay so that makes this over
here pi 0 to minus alpha or you could
call this one alpha in fact I'm gonna
put all those PI on to minus alpha there
because they are adjacent angles that
makes alpha over here and alpha over
here happy yep
no no so so that's yeah that's kind of
okay like I mean what's what's biggest
st is do you know what directions things
going in and to be honest I think that's
perfectly sufficient like you know same
thing up these are verticals it's kind
of the point of the whole diagram right
so I don't think you need to go through
lots of reasoning about Jason Daniels
alternate angles I think this diagram
itself is sufficient okay so now that
I've got all the right angles in the
right spots which is tricky now I'm
ready to actually use trick to work
these kinds of things out again I've got
a horizontal component and a vertical
component I'll call this one imagining
me exit n and just because I've run out
of space over here i'm going to put why
ok but of course that's equivalent to
wear hear what my actual victor it so
someone tell me what am I going to use
let's do the horizontal one first how do
I relate this horizontal force to the
novel ok so I'm very good cons alpha
equals chaser or hypotenuse right so
from this I just read off that if I make
it in the subject that's going to be
cons it's fine and you're like oh right
that's like this is back in the normal
scheme of how many siblings because
using this geometry in here you can see
are now it's equivalent to me on the
unit circle measuring from the
horizontal do you see that ok so that's
good what else have I got here to get to
this guy I'm going to use opposite of
hypotenuse rates that's why sign comes
in
so from that I'm just going to read off
here we go this is an done alright so
I've got all of these forces resolved
but the last step that's important is to
combine all of them to say well what's
actually happening and how do each of
these bits and pieces contribute to
what's happened ok so this is um sensi
of the question but it's moving in a
horizontal circle uniform circular
motion ok so that means on a vertical
scheme what's happening up and down
answer nothing right so on a vertical
scheme but net force is zero right so
I'm going to look at all of the vertical
forces I have all of them including this
guy and if i add them all up including
their directions they should all add to
zero ok so i can put it all is this so
I'm going to say it vertically
stationary ok so then have a look how
many forces can you see that I'm
oriented up and down I can see one two
three one two three right you can see
there's this guy which is facing upwards
positive you've got this work which is
also facing upwards and then the third
one years yeah the weight force which is
going down ok so i'm going to write that
in that order with those signs that are
informing those directions so I've got T
coz theta plus M sine alpha minus mg
equals zero okay you're often see for
instance in the solutions to the
textbook you will often see this written
just as one extra step they're just
going to write this in a balanced form
ok by which they need look these are
going up these are going down it's not
moving so there must be exactly equal to
each other I've said to you before I
still prefer this because it informs
direction like where is this one you're
like which ones up which one's down
order whereas this I think is just a
little more informative that was very
quick now horizontally
it's moving in uniform circular motion
okay so therefore I have again a look
again and I say well we're all of the
horizontal forces going and they should
add together to make em r omega squared
in toward the center okay now this is
slightly more interesting because when
you have a look at the horizontal forces
they are opposed to each other right so
this one's heading away so i'm going to
call this one positive this one has had
negative so it's heading I'm gonna sorry
it's heading into the center something
to call that negative and in summary
they all are heading in negative right
so i'm going to write let's see q + cos
alpha minus T sine theta equals minus M
Omega square okay um again because you
know we have this hatred towards
negative sides you will often see this
written as T sine theta minus and cars
are fun because they're just multiply
through yeah um and that is fine it's
still correct as you can see because
he's like the lint but I still kind of
like this one because this is what makes
uniform circular motion happen it's a
force toward the center
um it is ok to define it but it is
unconventional so if you were to do that
i would say something about it in the
same way that I'm for a projectile
motion question no one would bat an
eyelid if you didn't say up is positive
and a way is also positive right because
it's like well that's what we always do
but we don't have to you know when we've
looked at an object that you know
falling personal we can define it as
negative and so you say something
exactly all right so my question is done
now I just want to point out before I
show you the rest of these that I've
already I've prepared earlier what makes
this remember I said our mechanics right
what we add is an understanding lot of
mass and therefore forces that's what we
we have which is mu vs extension 1 okay
the second thing which is kind of you is
that this is what a projectile motion
resolution diagram looks like but in
mechanics region we don't care about the
poor facing the same duration you know
they always face this way for
projectiles when we define them to be
but in mechanic's uniquely you've got
them all facing which all kinds of
directions and so therefore you have to
be careful you've got to set this up
whichever way it's going as you're
seeing all these other diagrams they'll
be facing in all kinds of different
directions so you need to be able to
distinguish between those and therefore
the sides the science really matter ok
things like this